l'enseignement d'exploration eps en
seconde et son prolongement cycle de
terminale sont enseignées au lycée les
cette mare de maurepas à plus de 100
élèves chaque année mais les nouveaux
textes officiels des programmes du lycée
du bac font disparaître l'enseignement
conséquence les actuels élèves de
seconde ne pourront pas poursuivre
l'enseignement suivi cette année c'est
totalement des prisons pour les
enseignants puissent qu'on nous impose
maintenant des programmes qui sont un
faisable dans les horaires impartis
avec des choix de programmes qui sont
fortement contestables les élèves ont
porté des tee shirts verts couleur de
l'espérance et se mobilisent pour garder
cet enseignement avec cinq heures en
second des quatre heures en première et
terminale
ça aurait pu permettre à plein de jeunes
de porc comme moi se défouler pour
comment pouvoir s'exprimer dans d'autres
matières que dans les matières où il
faut forcément à prendre des parents
sont venus soutenir les professeurs de
ps lors de cette manifestation
le sport pour moi se répartit une grande
conviction des choses très importantes
de la vie de de l'évolution et ça serait
vraiment dommage de sacrifier
cette spécialité qui en est une
actuellement cet enseignement est
implanté depuis presque vingt ans dans
l'établissement
les professeurs de ps espère interpeller
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer air afin d'obtenir des moyens
peuvent recréer un enseignement
optionnel
pourquoi dire qu'effectivement il faut
lutter contre l'obésité contre la
sédentarité et au final des actes qui
sont au contraire les professeurs
parents et élèves souhaitent que
l'ancien enseignements d'exploration et
de compléments implantés dans plus d'une
centaine d'établissements puissent se
transformer en enseignement de
spécialité afin de poursuivre le travail
engagé